hello and welcome to this video playing
hypnotic specter here on the ICC yeah
let's see what is going to do they are
not quite sure how to handle this game
because um it's always a little bit of a
tricky subject this is some jerry's
account chest network um then yeah
there's been some discussion on reddit
if you should say that it is account or
whatever yeah this is account can you do
well see what happens here we have a
sloth defense and I'm playing this side
line against the Schlachter sloth it's
not so easy for black here to play white
is a little bit more comfortable it's
nothing particularly dangerous for black
but yeah he has to be a bit careful t5
is hanging
Blackey normally takes on b5 now Queen
takes Queen D 795 and him why does some
supposed to be a little bit better so I
don't quite remember however how it is
played I'm not sure b3 Bishop d2 one of
the two I think I think Bishop d2 where
I cannot I cannot quite remember the
problem that black has here is that that
a 7-pole is constantly under attack by
the night so it's not so easy to move
the a8 rook yeah that's certainly a move
that makes quite some sense question is
do I take along do I play 93 93 is a
little bit more a little bit more
interesting I think this is probably
better if five there is 96 oh it's
interesting he tries to regroup to c6
okay interesting idea I can't think I'm
not trying to do something fans you just
put put this on the tea farm it's still
not so easy here I wonder if this is
necessary I can also go before
immediately yeah let's do it
gaining some space still not so easy for
him to regroup on the queenside
hmm yeah rook c8 I guess it's uh no I'm
looking so what do I do here
let's just make this a little bit more
solid
again it's not easy light moves as Nazi
5 b6 okay
I would like to double on the C file
whoopsie - 94 94 multiform wins material
I think 97 asset the next move probably
yes it says some way to to exploit this
Knight f4 it's not doing much I can play
and I can take and play b5 I get this is
too much
well doesn't help
seems well defended him hmm yeah wonder
if going back is actually an idea cannot
cookie for that it would have been
interesting actually
who came mmm okay yeah that doesn't just
do much him he's threatening this now
taking on deform Bishop takes I have the
capture yeah well defended public that
was a really uncomfortable position and
he defended this very well so try to get
the bishop around over to g3 Bishop h6
might be a good reply him owner than a
group I have rook takes his six
indisposition rook takes his six Roxy
696 check King D six is that working
hmm almost oxy six boxes 695 shaking
these six it's not quite working but
close again but unfortunate that this
didn't work so we'll be up to six now
time morning no it's not much going on
here a little bit behind on time
maybe 95 here t-spawn chicks yeah
yeah I met my time is not looking so
great I maybe I should have just played
95 which forces the draw yeah it
probably was an idea just just for
something that is a bit easier a bit
easier to fly this is a little bit
difficult okay
no there's seven here
that doesn't look great for him he's
just cannot move here check check check
night will come to e7 he defended this
very well but made an endgame mistake
for its time I had a quite a nice
position out of the opening but very
well defended here by black so let's see
I mean this is some believe to be
somewhat awkward for black and when we
saw we kind of saw wine 93 98 good move
good move
okay this this looks you one King to
seven well this looks very logical I
mean three be six somewhere here I'm
losing losing the plot may be a route c2
is just wrong and did the three traits
too much I can do like h4g for this kind
of things
maybe yeah this this seems to be your
okay for him yeah now especially ninety
form they have to play something awkward
get the engine wants to go roots III
that's maybe a bit bit more active it's
very okay now everything here there
should be one and here yeah now I be
five wins damn it it felt like there
should be something you know because
this yeah this is something that I saw
but now now I have nothing
yeah I can I cannot I cannot win this
position here and I can take here that
this is just
for loss and this this ob5 it's also
interesting that is this and now I'm
threatening here and here
cling c7o ever saving the day for black
yeah okay I can do this and it's a draw
but I can play b5 and win the game this
is this is great yeah I didn't see that
more now very nice
the idea is that black has to take if he
if he has to if he moves the night
somewhere
yeah like here it's very easy I go here
and I win stuff know what that Bishop
before is having its same so takes and
now I can take Jack because now this is
not doing anything yeah okay well yeah
yeah but this is it's picking up a whole
rook so here I had a win yeah it felt
shaky yeah this Bishop FA but I I didn't
didn't think about b5 here very strong
yeah okay I played this and here we have
a an equal position maybe I should have
played 95 now just for simplicity sake
because the game position was still and
somehow we don't see the time you have
to probably restart the software and the
game position was a bit tricky with no
time on the clock I mean here we get
Jerry get get me to get this Jack Jack
which is an immediate drawer I think
they have more space by it's a draw
that's a joy yeah this is I mean I can't
play those moves I just said the game
continues and it could be tricky with no
time on the clock
in form yeah this yeah the engine gives
gives this and this is actually
something that scared me a bit during
the game but I can take this this and
continue for yeah that I never would
have found I think with no time yeah it
starts to be a little bit difficult a
computer this loses ultimately the
computer wants to do this and says it's
a draw
so why does it draw maybe I'm drowning
trapped here or something check check
I okay so if I'm going back now I'm
getting trapped with the night and if
I'm going up check I'm shining perpetual
tea anyway so he can still draw this
only after the attack it's it's losing
yeah I'm dominating the night and Jack
the pawn is Jack Jack is doing it strong
yeah he lost on time yeah well defended
initially only at this this is this
single chance this b5 move which would
have been very nice if I would have
spotted it and but okay I was a danger
of falling behind on the clock and I
don't want some kind of mouse waits at
the end he definitely is very good at
yeah equal ish game or long probably a
draw would have been fair but at the end
his crew love the endgame
okay I hope you enjoyed the video thanks
for watching